allez on y va alors michel espié près en
faire une interview première fois donc
d'accord ton premier souvenir c'était
dans ma chambre j'étais monté sur une
petite chaise que j'écoutais de la
musique et je faisais ce qu'il était
chef d'orchestre un bilan et un frère
aient trouvé ça complètement stupide
c'est une somme énorme en ce moment là
tu avais raté concertiste était pianiste
julie à quatre mains tous les deux n'ont
gère un professeur tapé sur les doigts
une règle pour le solfège
sinon c'était ma grand mère m'a plu
piano et puis étudie tout le monde croit
que je sors du conservatoire en fait
c'est pas vrai ou pas j'ai aucune
technique du musical d'abord elle croit
qu un bon pianiste est totalement sous
un pont très très mauvaise il a appris à
vivre elles étaient des faux alors oui
mais aussi le premier disque que tu as
acheté ça c'est notre charge
le premier vise haut à schaerbeek c'est
une pochette blanche et intitulé j'ai dû
faire à la maison quand même temps c'est
en tout cas à l'intérieur la seleccion
la première fille avait quitté ses
labours bas étaient blancs parce que moi
je suis très partisane savoir par qui
c'était et c'est comme lire de la
musique sans connaître la partition quoi
première fois j'ai eu une petite eu dur
c'est très très vite vers ce biais à oui
parce que je vais moins 15 ans j'ai
commencé à gagner ma vie alors
maintenant des chansons ce qui était
quand même très particulier et j'ai très
vite assez indépendant j'ai le même
studio et voilà le premier garçon le
clip que je fais l'amour est vrai que ça
c'est une expérience que j'ai pas eu
mais en même temps j'ai beaucoup de
tendresse pour les gens qui aiment les
garçons les choses par contre je serais
pas content qu'il y ait un truc fils est
mort
je suis incroyablement attirés par les
jeux ne sont pas avoir trouvé beau un
mec vraiment par exemple je te trouvais
beau aujourd'hui qu'est ce tu fais un
bon jour aucun tabou moral par rapport à
cela la première chanson et c'est vrai
que c'est pour bourvil et que c'était la
girafe
ouais c'est ça la tuque pas c'est un
sujet qu'il est vraiment aidé à voir ce
que pourront bien physiquement mais
c'est un type extraordinaire moi j'étais
je voulais dans les lacs avec bourvil
c'était le directeur artistique de celui
des pâtes et qui s'occupait de la
plaignante me sens bien qu'ils étaient
très c'était une époque où c'était les
jeunes qu'il est la loi il avait envie
de faire travailler déjà le look avons
revu ouais et ont vu il était
formidablement
à droite on flotte sur wii pour vous
parce que vous avez chanté moi c'était
pas du tout mon truc j'ai ce qui
m'intéresse c'est les beatles et et mais
moi écrivez moi ça au contraire j'adore
va s'afficher chrétiens sont conduits là
absolument pas gentil comme un truc que
c'est devenu temps semble bon rythme
mais ça m'a permis vl studio parfait
est ce que t'as pas vu un complexe soit
vis-à-vis du rock and roll tu dis
toujours je fais pas du recadrage fait
la retenue il flaire de 10 rebonds s'est
pas complètement du rock and roll est ce
que t'as pas été est ce que finalement
qui est passé d un côté bonne élève
tu serais pas assez dit ce treuil pour
elles peuvent en revenant à passer à
l'intérieur ça se passe et je pense que
le ministre de l'intérieur handicap par
rapport à sa part les notaires tout à
l'heure ouais c'est que j'ai la très
sage compte finalement que leurs bons
gars et bien habillée au sommet et se
croient que c'est à l'intérieur ça se
passe assez bien ta première production
c'est vrai que c'était déjà limite 7
jeezy c'est un allemand les règles
canular ça m'a permis d'aller
l'exclusion par la reine victoria match
et c'était un petit peu seul eu l'idée
de lorient qui avait fait 1
amis sur le web la toile y met et nous
on s'est dit on n'arrête pas de nous
dire eu la même idée américain c'est le
plus intéressant à l'europe c'est fait
pour les américains et on s'est dit on
va faire une liste voilà c'est comme
celle là quand elle chantait mais là
personne ne savait que j'étais nous
comprend et donc les programmateurs de
radio ont dit voilà c'est ça c'est
vraiment de la ligue américaine et celle
annoncée un pays fermé avec non c'est ça
oui on été pêché un petit pour chanter
en anglais et fatick et en a vendu un
million et un million et après tu a tout
perdu en faisant un 33 tours s'appelait
puzzle voilà geste est quoi ce polar
j'avais gagné je vais me en deux jours
qu'un arc et saint félix
je voulais faire un concerto avec un
groupe avec une guitare électrique une
basse et une batterie alors que cinq
villages avaient vendu 310 écoles et non
plus celle que je devais faire par la
suite on était dedans mais ces termes
notre pied extraordinaire que j'écoute
de poisson c'est inaudible ton premier
drame dans ta vie c'est et quand le vrai
drame seront très fier de mon frère
était très proche et qui était
c'est lui qui m'a appris beaucoup
beaucoup trop dray
la famille s'appelant toile s'est
suicidé aussi oui c'est vrai ça s'est
produit le drame
c'est un ami d'enfance avec lequel j'ai
facilité la france qui s'est suicidé
pourquoi je crois que son histoire
d'amour
justement y arrive ton premier amour
grand amour mais moi j'ai eu très peu
d'amour c'est véronique sanson
premièrement oui je crois que c'est à
peu près le prévenu est important vous
avez rompu pourquoi tu sais c'est qu'il
faut demander qu'on lui a demandé ses
pour comparer c'est comme si on met pas
les munitions qui vivait avec son 2e
quand amour elle a écouté je crois que
c'est la vie et que je suis maintenant
donc tu vois c'est vachement ces dames
et fidèle oui assez julien clerc nous a
raconté que lui ont quant à elles été
avec lui il était un peu dans l'ombre et
que toi au contraire il a mis dans la
lumière droit que c'est ça enfin en
dehors de l'amour qui éventre vous est
ce que c'est ça qui vous a réuni ailier
pour longtemps je sais pas tu sais je
crois que si je suis très difficile de
dire pourquoi ça va d'un couple qui
après ça va plus je crois que c'est très
très difficile en tout cas de passer sa
vie à quatre personnes ça al'air de
détournement de loin ça va 100 ça
miraculeux légère quand c'est à dire à
certains de l'année ton premier succès
personnel
quant à chanter des chansons le premier
truc a vraiment marché de toit par toi
la mobilité yannick dago pianiste ouais
ça ça a été tout d'un coup ça a été
incroyable parce que tout d'un coup nos
villages là j'étais pas je donne donc
lui le non jeu c'était déjà de quatrième
ou cinquième album tintin à huy ha vu
plein de gens qui commençaient à penser
comme chanteur s'était c'est un peu
compromis est plutôt une chanson pour
les autres grands exemple quand il ya
des moments où le dos et non j'arrête je
fais des chansons pneus aux autres moi
j'arrive à bord n'ont à aucun moment
n'ont pas le cas c'est ouais c'est pas
un peu vrai ton premier cheveu blanc
s'en souvient et en quelle année moi je
sais avant tout à marquer c'est vrai tu
peux avoir des comme ça le texte plein
1980 oui dans un article interview
georges marc benamou dans le quotidien
pareil tu viens à vous d'avoir ton
premiers cheveux blancs et gêné tout un
plat ouais je savais absolument pas ce
qui allait arriver